uh speaking of balance that's
complicated i
i wonder because we're living through
one of the more important
moments in human history with this
particular virus
it seems like pandemics have at least
the ability to
uh kill off most of the human population
at their worst and they're just
fascinating because there's so many
viruses in this world there's so many
i mean viruses basically around the
world in the sense that
they've been around very long time
they're everywhere
they seem to be extremely powerful and
they're just in a distributed kind of
way but
at the same time they're not intelligent
and they're not even living
do you have a like high level thoughts
about this virus that uh
uh like in terms of you being fascinated
about terrified or
not somewhere in between so i believe in
frameworks right
so like one of them is evolution
like we're evolved creatures right yes
and
one of the things about evolution is
it's hyper competitive
and it's not competitive out of a sense
of evil it's competitive in the sense of
there's endless variation in variations
that work better when
and then over time there's so many
levels of that competition
you know like multi-cellular life partly
exists because of
you know the the competition between you
know different kinds of life forms
and we know sex partly exists to
scramble our genes so that we have
you know genetic variation against uh
the invasion of the bacteria and the
viruses and it's endless
like i read some funny statistic like
the density of viruses and bacteria in
the ocean it's really high
and one-third of the bacteria die every
day because of viruses and painting them
like one-third of them wow like
like i don't know if that number is true
but it was like
like there's like the amount of
competition and what's going on is
stunning
and there's a theory as we age we slowly
accumulate
bacterias and viruses and as our immune
system kind of
goes down you know that's what slowly
kills us and
it just feels so peaceful from a human
perspective when we sit back and they're
able to have a relaxed conversation
uh and and there's wars going on out
there like right now
you're you're harboring how many
bacteria and you know the ones
many of them are parasites on you and
some of them are helpful and some of
them are modifying your behavior and
some of them
are you know it's just really it's
really wild
but you know this particular
manifestation is unusual
you know in the demographic uh how it
hit and the political
you know response that it engendered and
you know the health care
response it engendered and the
technology is gendered it's kind of wild
yeah the communication on twitter that
it uh every level
all that kind of stuff at every single
level yeah but but what usually kills
life the big extinctions are caused by
um
meteors and volcanoes that's the one
you're worried about as opposed to
human-created bombs solar flares are
another good one
okay you know occasionally solar flares
hit the planet so it's nature
oh yes yeah it's all pretty wild
you